Hey guys, and welcome
to the, oh, goddamn.
(laughing)
No, start over.
Gonna go from a 10
to a four, gaywise.
(electronic music)
Hey guys and welcome
to The Other Show,
my name is Chris
Kelly, and this is
Sarah Schneider
And we are the creators
and executive producers
of The Other Two and we are here
talking about the pilot episode
Episode One.
Yeah with Brooke and
Cary, Helene and Drew.
Hello, hello!
Hi you guys.
Hello, Hello.
Oh my God, Mom I
broke up with Lance!
What?!
Yes, two weeks ago.
Oh, honey.
Are you doing okay?
Yes, I'm great, I'm way
better than I was before.
No offense Lance.
What?
We always said that
Carey felt like us
in our twenties, and Brooke
feels like us currently,
when we're wasted.
(laughing)
The alarming part is that
is how I talk normally sober,
so it's really, thanks
a lot what a compliment.
I feel like while we were
shooting you were like,
"This is who I am, I feel
embarrassed that I am her."
No, truly I would read
scripts and be like,
"Oh, I think you wrote
this because I overshare.
I'm so sorry," and
it's just constantly
being projected at me.
Hi, I'm Carey
Dubek and I'm reading
for the role of man at
party who smells fart.
I guess people have only
seen the pilot at this point,
but I will say that it gets
rough and tough for you.
Yeah, it gets really tough.
I'd say you go on
fun journeys and you,
as an actor, get
humiliated at every turn.
Is that accurate?
Yeah, that's accurate.
There's something about
my face that reads as sad.
It's like this makes sense.
We'd have conversations
where we were like,
"ooh, he cried in the last one,
so he probably shouldn't
cry for at least two more.".
Yeah, halfway through
filming I was like,
"oh, I'm not doing comedy."
(laughing)
No, you are.
It's a fun comedy on Comedy
Central, Thursdays at 10:30.
(laughing)
Yeah.
I have seen one
dick in four years.
This summer, Imma see 50 dicks.
Eww.
No, it's empowering.
Well, I had been dating
someone for a very long time,
and so, and then after
that relationship ended,
I didn't go on a
quest to see 50 dicks,
but I was kind of like, I
am reborn, let's hang, let's
party, and got to two, and
then I married the second one.
(laughing)
And that was, she said
that on her wedding...
That was my vows.
Those were her vows.
That was beautiful.
Thank you.
Hi honey!
My embarrassing thing is
I worked at a restaurant,
an Italian restaurant
on the Upper West side,
and it was me and there
was one other gay waiter.
And one night my boss
literally pulled me aside
and was like can you
go get the other one.
I wanted you both
to know last night,
at my home, my wife and I
watched Brokeback Mountain.
Uh oh.
I didn't like it.
But, I watched it.
Thank you.
Is it bad that I sort
of think about that
and I'm like oh, sweet?
It was sweet adjacent.
Is he gonna be
like, legit famous?
No, there's no way.
Yeah, no, right?
I mean how big
could he really get?
(dramatic music)
Well there's the other
three in my family.
My sisters auditioned
for this show called
American Juniors, which was
a spinoff of American Idol.
The year after
Kelly Clarkson won,
and one of them
made it on the show.
Yeah.
And they flew our whole
redneck family to L.A.
And as soon as I got there,
I like went to Melrose
and I bought a white
belt and a Von Dutch hat.
So you were like
I'm gonna be on TV,
get me to a store
to buy a white belt.
Exactly.
And we sat on the
side of the stage,
and then they would like
cut to us and they'd be like
Tarvers, what do you think?
And we'd be like we love it.
But did people start
knowing you from the show,
'cause you were always
to the side of the stage?
Well, yeah you're
over to the side
and like, when you
leave the studio,
people would be like
Caitlin's brother!
That's great.
And I was like
basically at the time,
I was like you can
do nothing and people
will sort of scream your name?
I love Los Angeles.
Oh yeah, so did that made
your brain be like I love this.
Yeah
You weren't embarrassed
or like oh no?
The cool parts of
Carey where he's like
I don't want this, I'm better
than this, I did not have.
It was like oh
man, I don't know I
guess maybe I could
be Ryan Seacrest?
(laughing)
Oh that was what you learned.
Interesting.
Please let's cut this.
You aren't quite there yet.
(laughing)
I didn't wanna be Seacrest,
but he was from
Georgia and I was like
look what Seacrest did!
Buckle up girls, there's
a sexy new singer in town,
and guess what?
He just turned 13!
Case Walker, who plays
Chase, who plays the pop phenom
is not here, but I guess let's
talk about him behind his back.
Yeah, let's do that.
That is a whole other
part of this show,
which is us four, in
comparison to that.
(laughing)
Yeah.
To like a young, right
out the gate, I'm talented,
know what I like, know
what I do, know what
my brand is, know
what my deal is.
Yeah
That's Case.
We found him on the internet.
We found him on Musical.ly,
which is like an app
(laughing)
You can do it.
I can't even start talking
about it, I don't know.
I was there at some audition.
We brought you guys
to the call backs.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
He came in and was just
like, they were like,
"Case, what have you been
up to?", and he was like,
"I've just been
rising and grinding."
Oh, he said the
grind never stops.
The grind never stops.
He's like, ya know,
the grind never stops.
Which is what I think
Ken Marino Streeter says
in the pilot, and then
we have people say
so many things that
Case says in real life.
We're like, 'Can we
use this literally?'
Yeah.
I love this.
How do we wrap this
up, what do we say?
Seacrest would know how
to wrap this up, though.
Yeah.
Do it Drew,
here's your chance!
Be Seacreast, get
us out of here.
Alright, guys
well there it was.
(laughing)
That's it.
There it was, you
loved it, it's fun.
And make sure to tune
in later for House.
That's good, that works.
(laughing)
Speaking of current.
House is still on.
Right?
(electronic music)